قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان اوكرانيا استعادت نحو 50% من
الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا في بدايه
هجومها
واضاف في حديث لشبكه سان ان انه واثق من
نصر الاوكرانيين والنتائج الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد ستظهر خلال اشهر
لقد استعاد الاوكرانيون بالفعل نحو خمسين
بالمئه من الاراضي التي احتلتها في بداية
هجومها وهم الان ياخذون معركه صعبه
لاستعاده المزيد ولا نزال في الايام
المبكره نسبيا من هجومهم المضاد وهم
يخوضون معركه قاسيه حيث اقام الروز دفاعات
قويه لكنني مقتنع ان المعدات والدعم الذي
تلقته اوكرانيا لم يتم الزج به بالكامل
بعد في هذه المعركه وهم على عكس الروس
يقاتلون من اجل ارضهم ومستقبلهم وحريتهم
وهذا هو العنصر الحاسم واعتقد ان ذلك
سيتضح خلال عده اشهر